whittom avec roland lescure le ministre
en charge de l'industrie bonjour
monsieur lescure d'abord une réaction à
cet échange un peu musclé avec le
sénateur communiste pascal savoldelli
qui estime que et bien en disant qu
hubert a permis de mettre le pied à
l'emploi à certains jeunes des quartiers
populaires et bien vous avez un peu
manqué de respect à ces jeunes de
quartiers notamment de son département
du val de marne qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez car vous n'êtes pas pu lui
répondre durant cette séance m'a d'abord
que lui est un enfant du val de marne
moi je suis un enfant de la seine saint
denis est donc ces jeunes je les connais
comme lui j'ai eu la chance grâce
d'ailleurs à l'école républicaine d'en
sortir et je souhaite que tous les
jeunes des quartiers défavorisés
puissent en sortir l'art hubert ce n'est
pas la panacée on a eu l'occasion
d'ailleurs dans nos échanges de
l'évoquer les enjeux de précarité
précarisation pardon de l'emploi les
enjeux de fiscalité auquel d'ailleurs le
président de la république bruno le
maire et moi même nous avons nous sommes
attaqués pendant le mandat qui vient de
s'écouler on va continuer à s'attaquer
sur la régulation numérique sur la
fiscalité mais quand même il faut
reconnaître aujourd'hui si vous avez
déjà pris annulaire qu'on tombe souvent
sur des jeunes issus des quartiers qui
sont contents de s'être fait ce job avec
de la liberté avec une capacité à
organiser son emploi du temps et surtout
avec l'espoir d'aller ailleurs d'aller
plus loin mais c'est un marchepied
extrêmement utile qui souvent pour des
jeunes issus des quartiers populaires
est un premier pas c'est même à pas de
géant moi j'ai rencontré des chauffeurs
hubert qui rêvent d'une chose c'est
d'être chauffeur de taxi mais c'est un
bon marchepied pourriez être d'autres au
contraire qu'il souhaite ouvrir un
restaurant qui souhaite retourner aux
études faux pas je dirais jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain la fiscalité la
régulation la protection des données la
manière dont les employés sont traités
oui il faut s'y attaquer mais n'oublions
pas quand même ce que cette entreprise
ait d'autres d'ailleurs ont apporté à
des jeunes est ce que vous comprenez la
volonté des groupes de gauche au sénat
de créer une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire après les rumeurs files et
les révélations sur les liens entre
emmanuel macron ministre de l'économie
est justement ce groupe américain hubert
où on a appris que par exemple le
ministre est bien à
juste à jusqu'à conseiller certains
députés de porter des amendements écrit
par hubert alors je me garderai bien
d'entrer dans les prérogatives du sénat
ou de l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs
qui organise ces travaux de contrôle du
gouvernement comme il le souhaite je
voudrais quand même rappeler qu'un
ministre de l'économie qui rencontre des
agents économiques bah oui c'est normal
et moi en tant que ministre de
l'industrie j'ai déjà rencontré des
acteurs de l'industrie j'étais à tous
france lundi j'ai passé la journée avec
des acteurs de l'industrie qui souhaite
s'installer en france vous savez quoi le
scoop c'est que quand vous voulez faire
en sorte que des industriels viennent
créer d'emplois en france il faut les
rencontrer il faut leur téléphoner
parfois même il faut recevoir de leur
part des sms tout ça a été fait est
plutôt bien fait depuis maintenant un
peu plus de cinq ans par le ministre de
l'économie de l'époque devenu président
la république et par le ministre de
l'économie depuis 2010 est bonne au
maire moi je compte continuer à faire ça
pour finir un mot rapidement sur la
forme de la réaction est fière du
président de la république qui dit cette
affaire d hubert files et bien je cite
ça m'en touche une sans faire bouger
l'autre est un peu de vulgarité un peu
de un peu de mépris quand même coûté ce
que j'ai compris et je m'en souviens
parce que j'étais jeune à l'époque c'est
qu'ici tu est lui-même un autre
président de la république qui était
connu pour son franc-parler il a eu une
réponse franche et une questions
franches je pense qu'il faut surtout
retenir le fond de l'histoire le
ministre de l'économie il rencontre des
industriels des entreprises pour créer
de l'emploi en france c'est ce qui doit
nous rassembler merci beaucoup roland
lescure pour votre
[Musique]